with many people struggling to make ends
meet these days for some pets may no
longer be a priority many dog and cat
owners could use a little help caring
for them but where do you go for that
help in this special report Denise
Valdez tells us about resources for
everything from shots to food in some
cases it's free so I see appetite's not
a problem
Duke is a large lovable boy and best
friend to owner Robert Cruz he loves
being around people but he's more than
just a pet he's a Lifeline one of the
most loving dogs you can ever have for
fighting Cruz's depression and isolation
you saved my life you know
retired from the Marines and on a fixed
income the pair rely on Hearts Alive
Village and its low-cost vet clinic
people are running up against problems
for their pets all the time Christy
Stevens is founder and executive
director of Hearts Alive there's housing
issues that people are dealing with
there's the fact that they can't feed
them or get access to Medical Care the
clinic has full-time veterinarians
offering vaccinations Wellness checks
Dental Care at reduced prices to alter a
dog the cost ranges from 70 to 165
dollars depending on size an annual
health check 25 blood work starting at a
hundred and shots as low as 12. it
offers military discounts sets up
payment plans or applies for Grants so
pets and owners can stay together how
incredibly important it is to be able to
help those folks access care for these
babies keep homes together
keep animals out of the system
across town at Nevada SPCA food is going
out we've got dog food we got we got cat
stuff in the bottom yep thank you very
much almost as quickly as it's coming in
and our objective here is to be able to
offer them something so they can keep
the pet
free food
to owners like Angelia she comes by
every few months to pick up supplies for
her dogs and cats it's really expensive
particularly cat food really is
expensive cat wet food is expensive
there are no questions no qualifications
you just need to make an appointment
and the food is all yours we try to make
it as respectful as possible because we
know for some people it's hard to ask
for help but help is out there the
Heaven Can Wait Surgical Center has
served over 175
000 patients cats can be spayed or
neutered for 50 to 75 dollars starting
at twenty dollars your pet can see a
doctor for minor illnesses like skin
conditions or ear infections for Robert
you can't put a price on family I
wouldn't be where I'm at right now
without their help and without Duke
now none of these places handle
emergencies or long-term illnesses but
there's a lot of routine and
preventative care that you can get so
write down this number
702-496-0705 this is a seven day a week
helpline where you can ask how to get
food and supplies for your pet housing
that accepts animals lost and found
remember there are several organizations
who are working to keep your pet in your
home